>> YOU CAN'T TRUST THE
GOVERNMENT.
>> THREATS FROM NORTH KOREA.
>> MISTRUST OF GOVERNMENT.
>> WE SO MANY PROBLEMS IN THE
WORLD.
>> IT SEEMS LIKE THERE WAS NO
HOPE THINGS WOULD CHANGE.
THEN ONE MAN SPOKE UP.
>> THIS SONG IS ABOUT HIM.
THANK YOU, SCOTT.
♪♪♪
♪ TURNED ON THE TV
WHAT DID SHE SEE
BLOOD BEING SPILLED
WAR IN THE MIDDLE EAST ♪
♪ RESCUE SHE SEEKS
DID SHE CROSS THE SEA
WITH HUNDREDS OF DROWNING
YEARNING TO BE FREE ♪
♪ SHE COULDN'T SIT BY AND DO
NOTHING
HE HAD TO ACT BEFORE IT WAS
TOO LATE ♪
♪ HE SHARED AN ARTICLE
ON FACEBOOK
AND THEN EVERYTHING CHANGED
THANK YOU, SCOTT ♪
♪ YOU SOLVED A PROBLEM
SCOTT
YOU BROUGHT THE STRUGGLE
TO AN END ♪
♪ SCOTT
BY SHARING THAT ARTICLE
WITH 84 FACEBOOK FRIENDS
THANK YOU SCOTT ♪
♪ BUT THEN SCOTT REALIZED
THAT BLACK PEOPLE'S LIVES
MATTER AS MUCH AS THE LIVES
OF THE WHITES ♪
♪ SOME PEOPLE PROTESTED
AND GOT ARRESTED
HE HAS TO DO MORE TO
END THEIR OPPRESSION ♪
♪ HE KNEW HE HAD TO STAND UP
HE KNEW HE HAD TO MARCH
OVER TO HIS LAPTOP AND
WRITE BLACK LIVES MATTER ♪
♪ IN HIS TWITTER BIO
THANK YOU SCOTT
YOU ENDED RACISM
SCOTT ♪
♪ NOW WE'RE ALL EQUAL
SCOTT
AND COMPARED TO YOU
MLK DIDN'T DO [ BLEEP ] ♪
♪ AT ALL
THANK YOU SCOTT
YOU KNOW WHY I LOVE
THIS DUDE THE MOST ♪
♪ HE TELLS ME HOW TO FEEL
ON TOP OF TOP OF HIS POST
STORY ABOUT GOVERNMENT
RIPPING YOUR RIGHTS ♪
♪ GOT HIM PISSED AND
HE CARES SO HE SHARES
AND ABOVE RIGHT
WOMEN'S MARCH GOT ME LIKE ♪
♪ BIOFUEL GOT ME LIKE
AND WHEN HIS SISTER HAD A
BABY SCOTT LIKED
'CAUSE IT'S A ♪
♪ BIG DEAL
SO RAISE SOME HANDS
EVERY RACE COLOR AND
CREED FOR THE ♪
♪ MAN PULLING UP YOUR FEED
THANK YOU SCOTT
YOU'RE THE HERO
THAT WE WAITED FOR ♪
♪ SCOTT
WE WON'T EVER FORGET
SCOTT
THAT YOU FIGHT FOR ♪
♪ OUR RIGHTS FOR
YOUR PHONE WHILE
YOU'RE ON THE TOILET
SCOTT ♪
♪ DOING THINGS ON
THE INTERNET
SCOTT
THEN YOU POST THEM ♪
♪ ON THE INTERNET
FOR ALL THE LIVES THAT
YOU SAVED AND
THE BATTLES YOU ♪
♪ HAVE FOUGHT
THANK YOU, SCOTT ♪
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.